JONALIST IN GOOD STAING,
JEFF BEZ' NEWSPAPER?
[LAUGHS]
LOTS OF QUESTIONS HE.
WE HE TO G TO THE BOTTOM OF
ALL OFT.
WE'REOINGO START TONHT B
TAING TO THE CREOR OWHO
JOINS US RIGHT NOWIA PHONE.WE AN
SO I JT HAD TO ASK BAUSE IAM REY
SUOSE THE GERMAN GORNMENT
WAED TO SHUT DOW YOUR TWITTER
ED>> WEL I THINK THAT WHAT I A
DOING IS VERYFFECTIVE AND I
THINK THATOT OF PPLE
WAED TO SHUT ME DOW THEY
WANTED TO INTIMIDATE MENTO
SINCE, AND UNFORTUNATE FOR
THEM THAT IS JT NER GOING
TO HAPN.
>> Tucker:ELL, I A GTEFUL
TOEAR YOU ARE N INTIMIDATED.
ARE YOU A LILE SURPRISEDO
SEE OFLL PPLE TAYLO LENZ,
WHO COMPLAINED BITTEY WHEN WE
USED HER NAMON T AIR -- A[LAUGH]
SEVERAL MOHS AGO.
WHO WHINE AND CRIED ONTELEVISI D
BECAUSE PELE WERE CRITIZING
HER  MINE, WERE YOSURPSED
THAT IT WAS HER W CE AFTER
YOU PERSONALLYND TRIED TO
DESTROY YOUR LIFE?
>> YEAH, I THOUGHT THAT WAS
REAL HUMOROUS.
A NICE LAYER OF HUMOR ON TOPF
THE WLE STO, AND I THI THE
FACT IT WAS TAYLOR LORENZ, WHO
IS A KNOWN, YOUNOW, HYPRITE,
ISNOWN TO D PEOPLE, THEACT
IT WAS H HO IS DOING THIS, I
THIN IT HELPED PELE RALLY
PPORT FOR M
>> Tucke HAVE YOU -- I KNOWYOU R
PERHAPS YOU ARE,E DON'T KNOW
WHO YOU ARE, WHATRE YOU
SURPRISED THE PEOPL WHO ARE THE
MOST DEEPLY ENMHED IN
NAISSISM, TALKBOUTTHEMSELV THE S
>>ES, I'VE NOTICED AT A LOT.I N,
AS WELL, I TNK IT IS A BIT OF
A TREND
>> Tucker:BSESS OVER
MYSELF SO I AM LLINTO HURT
U.
WHA IS YOUR STATUS, SCE W
VE YOU ON THE PHONE, HOW ARE
YO DOING TONIGHT
WHE A YOU?
YOU DON'T NEED TOELL USHERE
YOU ARE BUT HOW HAS THIS EFFT
AR YOUR LIFEHIS JEFF BEZOS
PIE
>>ELL, THE PAST TWOAYS HAVE
BEEN VERY CHTIC AND
OVERWHELMING.
THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT
COORNATION THAT HA TO HAPPE
AND I AM NOW IN  LOCATION WHERE
DON'T THINK ANYON WOULD FIND
ME, NOT AT A OF THE LOCATIONS
THATAYLOR LORENZ LEAKEDR
AT AONE CAN FIND.
ITAS BEE A LITTL TOUGH BUT
I'M NOT GOING T